>> THE GAS STOVE BAN DEBATE IS
BOILING OVER.
AOC IS MOCKING REPUBLICANS WHO
ARE CONCERNED WITH A POSSIBLE
BAN, DESPITE HAVING ONE HERSELF.
>> I DO THINK IT'S FUNNY FA,
LIKE, ABSOLUTE UTTER REPUBLICAN
MELTDOWN, WHERE THEY'RE, LIKE,
YOU CAN TAKE MY GAS STOVE, OR
HOW DARE YOU TALK ABOUT GAS
STOVES.
YOU HAVE A GAS STOVE.
FIRST OF ALL,, FIRST OF ALL, I
RENT, PERIOD.
SECOND OF ALL, THOUGH, IT
DOESN'T EVEN MATTER, BECAUSE BY
THAT LOGIC THESE ARE THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO WOULD HAVE SAID WE
SHOULD HAVE NEVER HAVE GOTTEN
RID OF LEADED GASOLINE, JUST
BECAUSE SOMEONE MAY HAVE DRIVEN
A GASOLINE CAR.
NO SECRET GOVERNMENT AGENCY IS
GOING TO BUST DOWN YOUR DOOR AND
TAKE YOUR GAS STOVE AWAY.
>> YOU KNOW, VERY INTERESTING
ANIMATION, I SEE, IN HER TYRUS,
DON'T YOU?
>> YEAH.
>> YEAH?
THERE'S THAT GOLDEN RULE.
IF ANYONE HAS HEARD IT, NEVER
FILMING YOURSELF IS A GOOD IDEA
WHEN YOU'VE BEEN DRINKING.
THAT LOOKS LIKE WEDNESDAY NIGHT
WINE NIGHT.
TO SAY THESE MOCKING, IT HAS TO
BE CLEVER AND FUNNY.
WHENEVER YOU DO, THERE WAS NO
PUNCHLINE OR JOKE, AND SHE MADE
THE WEIRD VOICE, AND YOU REPEAT
YOURSELF.
FIRST OF ALL, THAT'S THE WINE.
STOP DRINKING AND FILMING.
YOU'RE NOT HELPING IT.
>> TYRUS AND I TALKED ABOUT THIS
AHEAD OF TIME.
WE THINK THE SAME WAY.
I COOK WITH GAS.
YOU COOK WITH GAS?
>> YEAH.
>> EVERYBODY WANTS TO COOK WITH
GAS.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF I KNOW HOW TO
COOK, BUT I COOK WITH GAS.
>> SHE USES THE GAS STOVE A LOT,
BECAUSE IF SHE THINKS IT'S
LINKED TO DECREASED COGNITIVE
PERFORMANCE --
>> THEY CAME FOR OUR LIGHT
BULBS, THE SHOWER HEAD PRESSURE,
THE TOILET WATER PRESSURE.
SO THEY'VE AWAY THESE THINGS.
I DO BELIEVE THEY ARE COMING
EVENTUALLY FOR THE GAS STOVE AS
WELL, IF ANYONE HAS EVER DONE A
RENOVATION, BUILT A HOUSE,
NOTHING TURNS OUT THE WAY IT
USED TO BE AT ALL.
IT'S LIKE LOWER POWER.
THIS IS ALL GOVERNMENT
REGULATED.
SO THERE'S NO REASON TO THINK
THEY'RE NOT COMING FOR THE GAS
STOVE.
>> THE TRUTH IS, GERALDO, THAT
THE NANNY STATE, IT'S GETTING TO
THE POINT WHERE WE'VE, LIKE, HAD
ENOUGH.
>> SHE HAS A PERFECT DEFENSE.
>> AND THAT IS?
>> SHE RENTS.
THE GAS STOVE WAS IN THE
PROPERTY WHICH SHE RENTED.
>> OKAY.
LET'S FORGET ABOUT THAT.
>> I RENTED MY CAR.
>> SOMEONE AT CNN SAID LIKE
HAVING A GAS STOVE IS LIKE A CAR
IDLING IN YOUR KITCHEN.
IS THAT RIDICULOUS?
>> I THINK YOU COULD DO A WHOLE
SERIES OF SHOWS ABOUT THE LACK
OF SCIENCE ATTACHED TO CLIMATE
CHANGE.
I THINK IT IS SCANDALOUS TO ME
HOW -- I REMEMBER "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" VERY CLEARLY, IT WAS
PURPORTED CLIMATE CHANGE,
ALLEGED CLIMATE CHANGE, POSSIBLE
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THEN ONE DAY THEY DECIDED
EDITORIALLY THERE WAS CLIMATE
CHANGE.
IT WAS AN IDEOLOGICAL POLITICAL
DECISION.
OF COURSE WE'RE CONCERNED.
OF COURSE.
ME, I THINK THE WORLD IS A LOT
CLEANER THAN IT WAS WHEN I WAS A
KID.
I MEAN, L.A. -- WHEN I MOVED TO
L.A. IN '63, YOU COULD NOT SEE
ACROSS THE FREEWAY.
>> THANK GOD FOR GAVIN NEWSOM.
JESSE, LET ME GET TO YOU ON THIS
THING, GAS STOVES.
>> IF YOU'RE 33, YOU CAN'T BRAG
ABOUT RENTING.
AND THAT'S A SHOT AT HER FIANCE,
A LOW-KEY SHOT AT THE FIANCE TO
SAY YOU BETTER PUT ME IN A HOUSE
SOON.
ALSO HER OPINION IS SAYING THIS,
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT COMES IN,
AND SAYS SOMETHING IS BAD FOR
YOU, AND TAKES IT AWAY FROM YOU,
THAT'S PROGRESS.
WHAT ABOUT PROHIBITION?
THEY CAME IN AND SAID ALCOHOL IS
BAD.
THEY TOOK ALL THE ALCOHOL AWAY.
THAT WASN'T PROGRESS, AOC.
AND OF COURSE WE'RE PARANOID.
THE GOVERNMENT SPIES ON US.
THEY LIE TO US.
THEY PROBABLY FUNDED COVID-19
AND PAID US GET A SHOT.
>> AND THEN LEFT IT IN THE
GARAGE.
>> AND THE STUPID WATER
PRESSURE.
I MEAN, MY HAIR LOOKS FLAT
TODAY.
>> THE SHOWER, WHERE THE WATER
COMES OUT STRONG.
>> I N